all right all right let's go there
the independent says
donald trump's civil war bombast is bad
enough democrats shouldn't help make it
worse oh oh man from noah burletsky is
mocking someone for not being as tough
as their rhetoric is not helpful if you
want a public discourse that doesn't
reward aggression so this is uh just one
of the many articles that are saying
donald trump civil war bombast or donald
trump calls for civil war blah blah blah
i love i love how they frame it they're
shocked and angered that donald trump
would discuss such a thing
from may 11 2022
the second american civil war is already
happening from robert reich okay
the conversation around civil war is not
just something trump brought up
apparently what happened is that on
truth social someone referenced uh naib
bakali i think is his name um the
president of el salvador
he tweeted a great nation like the us
you know can't be brought down from
the outside has to be from the inside
someone then quoted that and said civil
war trump then re-truthed it which is
their version of retweeting which is
terrible branding by the way but okay
let's live with it and uh
now they're saying trump called for
civil war
trump
is this his first mention of civil war
because this conversation's been
happening for four years and it started
with mainstream corporate press well
it's not his first mention of the civil
war at least
it might be it might not be but it is
the first time the media has ever
twisted his words and made it sound like
he said something different yeah yeah
that's that's true this is first you
know we've ever seen the media like
grasp at straws to make it seem as if
he's saying something completely
different than they could reasonably say
based on his statement so is is civil
war possible do you think it's i think
it's happening it's always possible
probable
i don't know i think i i tend towards uh
majid nawaz making a statement about
world war iii that it would be a bunch
of civil wars as well as a global war
corporate war neighbors on neighbors
information all of it let me tell you
why i think it's it's happening and it's
inevitable um
you need to understand what it what it
means in the context of fourth and fifth
generational warfare we often bring up
it may not get to the point where people
are fighting in the streets it may just
be what we're experiencing information
warfare
law fair media manipulation
in in this modern era do we need nuclear
weapons when you have the power of
propaganda well when i say civil war i
mean violence i mean it's already
happening
to some extent i mean organized violence
and and not just antifa rioters smashing
up buildings and beating people up uh
not just psychopaths randomly shooting
at people i mean organized a national
guard a governmental body yes and you
know i
i i vacillate on this right sometimes
when i grew up it seemed pretty
inevitable right and then in the 90s it
seemed pretty inevitable that the
country was going to break apart there's
so much hatred in the air so much
violence that was pretty much stamped
out by
the the response to 911 and all of that
sort of foment was pushed down by the
fear of the the you know nsa or dhs
picking you off and it just went cold
now it's starting to get hot again and
i i don't really see who
would be the combatants in a clear way
right you could say oh it's going to be
conservatives and liberals it's going to
be the urban versus the rural what would
that civil war map actually look like i
did get an insight on that though when i
think it was nbc published a map of
which states would pull back abortion
rights and which ones wouldn't and uh
i'm not saying that's a clear map of
what the the battle lines would look
like in the civil war but i think that's
a pretty good indication because you've
got a sacred value there and i think
that's what's
pretty much behind most of this conflict
is sacred values i think it's going to
be fairly north and south i mean
for the most part we're seeing abortion
laws like it's it's northern and western
states that are pro-abortion to an
extreme degree colorado for instance no
restrictions and it's many of the
southern states that are trying to
implement restrictions on it so you may
actually end up seeing this one i i i'll
reference the meme where it says the
united states of canada and um what was
it what was the other one the south was
called like the southern the christian
states of america and then and then the
north was the united states of canada
and it was like california but then up
and around like nevada and then you know
the midwest what people need to
understand about the first civil war
texas my understanding joined just
because of geography
texas was like well you know we're
basically locked in next to the
confederacy and if we don't join them
what happens who do we trade with how
does this work if we're a u.s state or
whatever so then basically like by
virtue of geography we're joining this
new union or whatever i think the same
thing would happen you will see more
conservative states that don't want to
align with illinois new york and
california but be like what choice do we
have north dakota and south dakota will
probably be roped up whether they want
to or not their populations are so small
they may they might have a choice that
could split the country honestly i don't
i don't really know all too well exactly
how to predict what would happen
civil wars like the u.s civil war are
rare in fact i'm not sure there have
been other civil wars exactly like it
where where multiple jurisdictions split
you know between north and south the
spanish civil war for instance was
pockets of urban and rural areas so we
may actually just see that and you will
see i mean new york's got a massive
urban police force tens of thousands of
people but i i think
what people uh
what what you need to understand right
now about what's going on is
geographic hyper polarization is
happening and will be exacerbated by the
supreme court's ruling on roe v wade and
casey you're going to get as you already
are
conservatives in liberal areas fleeing
red states becoming redder blue sits
becoming bluer and then eventually we
just completely disagree on everything
refuse to cooperate and then what
happens when
nevada puts up a border between
california or something because they're
like you allow illegal immigrants we
don't so we're building a border between
states these are the kind of things that
precipitate major conflict or how about
monkey pox it spreads and then all of a
sudden one state says we're enacting
border checkpoints between states so we
can keep out certain illnesses like we
saw with coven actually with connecticut
and new york
you guys are big on jonathan heights uh
moral foundations oh yeah i've heard you
talk about it
let's just take his theory for granted
right that human societies evolved so
that they diversify naturally towards a
conservative leaning and a liberal
leaning the conservatives obviously are
holding down the traditions liberals are
pushing society forward and through that
symbiosis that society goes forward
right forward isn't the right word when
i say forward i mean in a more adaptive
direction right so
according to heights theory uh what
you're talking about is humanity
essentially as certain pockets of super
organisms in which
having that variety having the the
variety of foundations to draw from in
any given problem to to face any given
dilemma you have a much greater chance
of solving it because of this diversity
of perspective right if we take that for
granted what's happening now with this
big sort in the u.s and what's been
happening really for decades but in the
last 10 years it's been extreme
you're in his theory you're basically
peeling the human organism apart you're
creating something that's profoundly new
that's never really existed before
because we're in completely uncharted
territory if that's the case now most of
my conservative friends listen to that
it's like oh well that's just a way to
legitimize liberal points of view and
push them on to me liberals love it
because it's all airy fairy and we can
all be together but i i honestly i think
that the the covid pandemic showed a
real flaw in his theory because
him and jesse graham by the way jesse
graham deserves a huge amount of credit
but
the idea that liberals skew primarily
towards care and fairness and
conservatives towards authority in group
preference and and purity and sanctity
i think on the surface that makes sense
but when you look at what happened
during covid you get a really good
example of how flawed that is because
liberals really did circle the wagons
and their sense of what is pure and what
is what is uh tainted or what is
polluting
really kicked on so whatever
you know whatever real distinctions
there are to be made there long term i
think that did show a real flaw and
height actually admitted that so
what i see happening is you have this
left wing and right wing and as you
mentioned you know the right the
conservatives are are holding back the
the left from going too crazy but the
left does bring about some changes
what happened is there was a weird
budding phenomenon where the left
started to have a growth of some sort
that was ignored and then eventually the
growth just got big and flopped off and
now is completely separate from the the
the us body
so you know in in this room we've had
actual liberals
and conservatives talk and disagree on a
bunch of core issues as you describe it
but the modern left in this country is
separate
the traditional left as you describe it
as pulling us forward
is considered right right-wing now
because that weird budding phenomenon is
slopped off and now is no longer
connected to the existing infrastructure
that is the rise of the multicultural
democracy within the united states
versus the constitutional republic it's
it's being fed it's being given sugar
and it's growing and eventually it will
either
burst and break or it will consume
the you know constitutional republic
side of things i think it'll probably
burst because these people have no logic
behind what they do it's wild tribal
nonsense
and they won't be able to adapt properly
they're not going to be able to survive
it really is if they are
the most extreme element of change
and no tradition tradition involves
things like growing food
they don't they don't know how to do
this if you look at that meeting with
the dsa where they're like hi my name is
john he him i just want to say that you
know please stop mr using gendered
pronouns for the group you saw that that
thing that went viral no the dsa meeting
everyone's freaking out they can't stop
fighting because they're like you know
someone says guys please stop clapping
you're triggering my my anxiety and then
a trans person goes
stop using gendered language and they're
all yelling at each other and it was
just it was crazy
that that's never going to function as a
system of governance those people will
not be able to grow food for themselves
don't you think they're puppets though i
mean do you really think that
that's not that's not relevant i mean if
you have eight million people in this
country who believe that they're not
going to survive a long fall
sure no but i mean they're being held up
clearly
to me i think they're just weaponized uh
misc malcontents right
the entire especially with the trans
movement i mean this is not something
that was was you know grassroots from
them uh you know they they pushed their
way into the public square
the left used them as a weapon against
the right and it shows i think in many
ways how devolved we are as a culture
that they got as much traction as they
did something as ridiculous as pronouns
and and whether or not one is being
misgendered as being some kind of key
issue for the nation i i i think that
they use these people to hammer on us
we're not talking about right now we're
talking about a collapse a conflict
civil war they can't exist sure no
definitely
if it collapses every transgender person
on earth will immediately start to
detransition and things will get real
not by choice no you're not going to
have access to
collective surgeries or medication but
it's not even about trans about the the
entirety of
the the um the left moral framework has
no merit
the the the left in this country doesn't
understand concepts of merit or logic
now i'm not saying literally every
single one of them but if you look at
their thought leaders we had we had a
tweet that went viral from hassan who is
the most prominent left-wing uh streamer
and he said something about capitalism
that there's only four companies that
produce baby formula and that was a
non-sequitur that idea makes no sense
it's not capitalism's fault there's only
four maybe formula companies it is not
four baby formula companies fault
there's no baby formula and there's not
no baby formula because there's only
four companies there's a nonsense
statement
if that's going to be the prominence of
thought
they're not going to actually solve the
problem of baby formula
so if everything did go belly up into
civil war or whatever
most farmers probably conservative i
don't i could be wrong about that but no
absolutely right
most conservatives live in rural areas
meaning they likely have on a scale of
one to a hundred
the 100 being you are a prepper
outdoorsman who can build a hut from
trees in a day and one being you are
absolute city folk if you if you're a
conservative you're leaning towards
outdoorsmanship so just living out here
in in west virginia i know what i can
eat outside a little bit i'm not going
to pretend to be any kind of proper
outdoorsman at all
but i know that i know when the food i
know in the wineberry season as i know
in the paw paw season i talk about all
the time hey i know where to get some
food i know where the turkeys are i know
what the animals are around here i know
where the bears are i know where the
deer are
you live in a city
let's say the store closes what do you
eat where do you get food you have no
idea
even if you leave the city you're going
to be like nah i'm in a random rural
place what do i do well unfortunately
for you you're going to have to go out
probably a hundred miles before you get
into even if you go 100 miles you're in
owned territory
so if you live in the middle of nowhere
if you live outside the suburbs you're
more likely to be conservative you're
more likely to know what to eat where to
eat where to get water you live in a
city you got none of that so good luck
yeah you know having lived in boston
portland and you know reared in
tennessee and now living in montana i
can tell you right now he's going to win
that conflict right i can tell you right
now who's going to last if things go
belly up do we need buzzfeed
when you know if the economy crumbles i
don't think we need them now but
definitely not then top 10 annoying
things that happen when you farm
the joke i made to the uh uh the the we
we have like a plot of land far away we
uh i don't i won't say too much but
there's uh recreational communities that
double as like in the event of an
emergency come out and i always tell
them like don't worry guys when when it
hits the fan and everything goes
crumbling if you need someone to
complain about stuff i'll be there
that's the job i can do right no as soon
as you show up they're gonna be like
start cutting wood and you're going to
be like yes sir that's it thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there
you